hi my name is Eric Andre
and I feel moist about being Conan
O'Brien's friend fantastic fantastic
shopping yeah now to be fair it's quite
humid in New York City
don't you dare backpedal
back pedaled out of that one fast don't
you I'm still gonna chalk it up to
weather conditions and not whatever you
whatever helps you sleep at night not my
sexual Charisma oh baby boy you came you
launched into this room full of pep and
energy and you were jacked you're in
good shape I'm not in great shape but
I'll take it you are now I've been I've
been
drinking a little bit when I drink I get
a little pudgy when I don't drink
slim up you slim up real good but I had
my 40th birthday party
and a month ago
and it lasted and yeah and I just you
went crazy I like cocktails what can I
say what's your favorite cocktail what
do you like
all of them
um
I don't know it's kind of like what's
your favorite album it's an unfair
question you're right I'm insulted that
you would ask such a thing no I like a
rum old-fashioned I like rum I love I
like rum a lot I love rum uh you got a
pirate kind of vibe to you I do have a
pirate Vibe and when I'm on rum I just
sprout an eye patch and a pirate and I
just it just grows out of me and I God I
love ROM yeah it's fun and then I like
to fight people yeah you know uh
a lot of rum uh history started in
Massachusetts Massachusetts was a huge
rum producer back in the day back in the
day so you got it in your veins brother
are you from Massachusetts well
originally from Ireland but then we hung
out in Massachusetts for a while before
you weren't born in Ireland no but it's
so funny you're from Boston aren't you
yeah I haven't from Boston but it's so
funny because my name is Conan O'Brien
and I look the way they do so many
people think I ask you from Dublin and
I'm like no I grew up in I grew up in
Massachusetts but uh you were born in
Ireland no no I was born in
Massachusetts so why did you lie to me I
didn't what did I say did I lie
he goes I'm I'm I started in Ireland and
then I moved to Massachusetts you did
thank you you did say I started in
Ireland yeah it was very strange that's
weird I subconsciously lied to you
uh why did I do that you're a strange
man you're drunk on rum well I'm gonna
say right now this is a Coke Zero it's
got nothing in it no I I started out in
Lebanon then it was off to Ireland for
my dreams to come true then I made my
way to Boston because I heard that was
the show business capital of the world
oh yeah turns out that was a mistake oh
right under the Citgo Stein that's where
everybody happens so it all happens
that's where they film Good Fellas and
Godfather all good movies start right
underneath the Citgo side under the
sickness to Fenway Park that's right
okay I'm gonna make sense of this
because we have things to talk about
tell me we can't we can't be screwing
around this is a serious interview do
you feel distracted am I creating a
distraction I think you should I think
you should go
I think
I'll send you my interview with Eric
Andre without Eric Andre
because you're uh yeah your distraction
I'm sorry you're getting in the way of
my interview with you yeah uh you uh
you're I love you you're great I love
you too you're a very funny man you're a
very creative man you're a Force for
good and uh I'm so I was very excited
that I'd be seeing you today I think the
last time we talked it was over zoom and
then today you come bursting in the door
yeah we hugged yeah we just I felt we
kissed for quite a long time you became
moist I felt your musculature then we
fought for a bit which surprised me it
didn't surprise me it shocked me you
took the first swing I came right I
blocked it came right back it was and
then I was doing major uh kickboxing on
you you were shocked I did tybo on you
which isn't a good defense no it's a
very good exercise great exercise you
weren't even Facebook as you did Tyler I
know and it made me easy to hit I just
was hitting you with a chair
I'm bleeding out and then you started
doing squats as I punched you in the
face I don't know I don't understand any
of it but uh and now we're very very
very happy to have you here and so glad
that your show is you got a new season
of the show coming out which people
absolutely adore you've got great people
on the show this year you always get
terrific guests you always get great
people to play along but who's who we
got this it's like John remember oh Jon
Hamm yeah little Nas X yeah good friend
of mine Lil yachty a lot of lils yeah a
lot of little porn star Mia Khalifa who
you're gonna pretend you don't know any
of her or Conan oh my God please this
morning I did a nine hour Deep dive
on her work
she enunciates the dialogue very well
that's what she's known for prediction
perfect I am the contaminer I didn't
notice anything else uh
um but you know uh you've gotta you've
got this great trajectory which is
you've made this show up completely it's
like sheer force of will you pretty much
made it all happen yourself in a lot of
ways right at the beginning this was a
homegrown project yeah it was a junkyard
show it was you and you were like when
you put together your show you were
living on couches yeah
yeah where I was like sleeping outside I
would sleep in like little Parks because
I was too afraid to sleep in Central
Park so I was sleeping like Saint
Martin's Park in Murray Hill and like I
would pick little and I had toothbrushes
all around town and I would hit you had
two as much just hidden in the Park yeah
[Laughter]
Third Rock
from the pond to the left here it is
Oral B with Sensodyne I would like I
would do stand-up at night I would do oh
Mike so I would ask the audience if I
could sleep over and sleep on their
couches and you meant it then I meant it
I meant it wow okay and so you start
putting the show together and then
um did it heat up in here or am I
excited
what do you mean don't you feel it gets
hotter than when we started yeah that's
your body heat you think it's just
you're glowing
I'm pregnant there's a there's an
omelette cooking on your shoulder it got
hotter I think it got hotter because I
don't mean to
flatter myself but I think you saw me
and I think you thought I'm sitting
with that Conan O'Brien that's what I
didn't realize that's right and you had
to up your game I looked into those
Lebanese eyes and I knew Lebanese Irish
eyes and you knew you had to take it up
a notch
you know